in cana bridge of spirits everyday items
are imbued with emotional significance a
wooden mask is a link to the spirit of
the person it was made for objects like
a hammer or a box of food are tied to
memories of people who have been lost
locations that were once the sites of
happy times are scarred with the pain
and trauma suffered within them looking
at common things with new eyes is a
running theme of kana and that theme
often applies to its gameplay as well
though the game is filled with some
fairly common action-adventure genre
tropes it has melee combat and climbing
similar to games such as star wars jedi
fallen order or even sakuro shadows die
twice platforming that recalls games
such as ratchet and clank and puzzles
like you might see in the legend of
zelda it manages to combine a familiar
approachability with some fresh spins on
the ideas those elements combine with
emotional character-driven storytelling
some tough but excellent fights and
mechanics that make the world feel alive
around you
the story and world of cana bridge of
spirits center on a village beset by
tragedy its inhabitants are all gone
wiped out by misfortune and their pain
has manifested as poison in the once
vibrant land around it that pain has
drawn cana a young spirit guide to seek
out the trauma at its center and heal it
while also searching for answers to her
own personal tragedy
i sense suffering here spirit
do you need help her link to the spirit
realm allows her to interact with the
ghosts of the past and to help them find
peace and in so doing she's able to push
back the corruption that has gripped the
land restoring it to its former glory
you do that by wandering the village and
its surrounding environs battling the
corrupted spirits of both the people who
once lived there and the nature their
pain has twisted most every interaction
comes down to a combination of combat
and puzzle solving your goal is usually
to beat down some enemies freeing up the
ability to destroy a nearby corrupted
heart with a blast of spirit energy you
can pulse from kana with the touch of a
button kill the heart and the corruption
recedes along with the corrupted enemies
combat is mostly familiar with kana
fighting off enemies with the use of her
spirit staff you get light and heavy
attacks you can combo together but even
in normal difficulty enemies hit hard
and can knock you off your game if
you're not paying attention like similar
action games you have a dodge to avoid
attacks with the right timing and a
shield that will stop most blows take
too many hits and the shield breaks
sending you flying and dealing you
damage but if you can time your block
just right you'll parry an enemy and
open them up to a counter-attack
both kana's puzzles and its combat add a
twist in the form of the rot which are
little spirit pals you can find in the
environment the rot are a bit like
pikmin or the minions in games such as
overlord in combat you can send them to
attack or distract enemies and you need
their help to destroy hearts which can
stop more enemies from respawning the
rot are the thing that makes kana stand
apart from similar games and using them
effectively adds a tactical layer to
fights since the rot are all pretty
small you need to work up their courage
to bring them into a battle as you deal
damage and kill enemies you fill a meter
that gives you a rot action
and you can send them out with a single
button or use them to power up one of
your attacks for a big hit the rot are
also crucial for taking advantage of the
environment to destroy hearts or to heal
kana working with the rot in combat
forces you to constantly be on the
attack and to pay attention to your
environment it's often essential that
you knock out smaller weaker enemies to
build rot charges so you can distract
and take down bigger tougher ones
deciding how best to use the rot in
combat keeps you balancing a big picture
view of the fight with the smaller more
intense moments of parrying a hit or
sniping a weak point occasionally the
combination of those elements can be a
bit annoying because it's easy to miss a
single dodge or block and have tough
enemies lay into you or to accidentally
send the rot to attack the wrong enemy
as things get hectic with some bosses
you'll probably need to die a few times
just to figure out how badly they're
capable of wrecking you but the game is
always quick to get you back into the
action with as little punishment as
possible it also offers a story mode
difficulty which seems like a very good
addition given how deceptively difficult
some of its fights can be heinous combat
is generally tough and exciting
executing well on familiar dodge and
parry mechanics but it's the addition of
the rot and the versatility and how you
can use them that really makes fighting
in kana feel fun and intelligent that
also goes for the game's various puzzles
outside of combat the rot can be sent to
do contextual actions in the world like
moving climbable objects to help you
reach a high platform kana does a good
job of combining the need to give the
rot commands with smart uses of kana's
abilities creating situations in which
solutions need you to think about what
you can do with your unlockable bow or
platform levitating bombs as well as
what the rot can do to alter the
environment it never gets too complex
but it's enough to make you feel like
you're doing a lot as you explore
where kanan nails the balance is in
providing you with tons of little
puzzles that mostly reward your
observation skills without overly taxing
your ability to solve them most of the
time spotting something the rot can move
or seeing an object you can interact
with using spirit energy is enough to
illuminate the path forward or some
hidden secret kana is also brimming with
collectibles including hidden rot
spirits and hats to customize them
chasing those items isn't essential but
the addition of all those little side
paths and tiny rewards encourages you to
explore and lose yourself in cana's
world and it is a beautiful world to
explore thanks to the phenomenal art
direction and an excellent immersive
score and made more so by the stories of
the spirits found within it the game is
full of cute characters and gorgeous
cutscenes that help to invest you even
further in uncovering what has happened
in the village and setting it right in
each section of the game you venture out
to find one particular tormented spirit
and help them achieve peace and your
journey through the location is all
about piecing together the story of who
these people are and what became of them
your interactions with the characters
you find in each section of the game
helps imbue the areas in and around the
village with a character all their own
easy there old friend
i'm happy to see you too
what's missing from the story though is
kana herself the game hints that some
tragedy in kana's past has scarred her
much like the spirit she sets out to
help but the game never really spends
too much time on her history and it
seems like some of those plot threads
are left dangling in a game where so
much development is given to the stories
of the inhabitants of the village it
doesn't feel like enough attention is
paid to kana by comparison the act of
meeting and understanding all those
other characters is powerful though k9
bridge of spirits is a game about making
those connections just like it's about
making a connection with the game world
around you through the rod
it's about exploring a world and seeing
what it once was and helping to restore
it to be that again and while cana
bridge of spirits is full of familiar
feeling combat and exploration its
ability to find different ways to look
at those ideas makes for a beautiful
emotional and exciting journey
[Music]